what's up gamers it's me what are you
doing oh I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I
please don't hurt me you're not even
wearing the merch hey everyone
new merch link description let's just
jump into this guys leave your entry
zenus already closed know why youtube's
favorite show voted by top youtubers the
number one show it's been an honor and a
privilege now we're at 80 million
subscribers but wait they are getting
close
what is this the sub gap is getting too
close we've been too distracted with
stupid memes that we forgot what the
real battle is what do we do honestly I
mean we've done everything I guess it's
over I don't know hey almost 1 million
subscribers what the hell come on guys
subscribe to PewDiePie submissions Jesus
from Fiverr was raised in a cult but
YouTube helped him break down ok so we
already talked about this video I've
seen the video it's a very heartfelt
video he also made an update video I
wish I wanted to see PewDiePie saves
Jesus again fellow disciples it's me
your favorite Lord and Savior Jesus and
this is going to be a happy video still
different from my typical video but it's
really important to me that I thank
someone who has changed my life in a
tremendously good way st. Felix has
saved my holy ass not once twice
therefore being banned from Fiverr and
now again for I might be my greatest
challenge to date so I have something I
never really intended anyone else to see
but I think this might be a good time to
share now so also if it's not obvious by
now I'm a very emotional guy so even
though I'm happy I'll cry so it's just
it's something that I do but anyways
this was recorded two years ago when
Felix came to
I rescue for the first time I don't even
remember I fighters clearly lost it I'm
making a video on this okay what
something really great just happened I
don't know why I'm crying I don't know
why I'm really happy about this but I
guess I'm just relieved whoo
okay I just found out like right just
told me that PewDiePie posted a comment
on my Oh video about being Benford fiber
then saying that he's gonna make a video
for me I don't remember making a video
did I make a video I do remember
donating better oh she has like shocked
I don't know what to say oh thanks
it's just it's like a huge relief Jesus
literally the impact you know just me
commenting and we're making a video into
something hasn't I actual people that's
crazy
thanks a lot Felix I really appreciate
it man anytime brother I think it's also
important to note that you know he's
thanking me but in reality you should be
thanking you guys sort of everyone that
watches I'm really proud that this
channel is so open and willing to help
other people in need I think that's
really cool and I'm just reacting to it
I'm not doing anything it's you guys so
I honestly give yourself a pat on the
back and apply some g fuel with third I
met a look-alike couple at my mall
versus Malaysia I think this is Malaysia
I recognise that uneven sideburns
anywhere she's good what do you made
uneven sideburns yeah Malaysia was crazy
and legit I'm never going back we were
just swarmed by his fans I don't I don't
say I don't like you guys I will be more
careful about channels I shout out in
the future yes
Oh see I spent five million dollars
keemstar who's going to be in this Super
Bowl mr. B's a pity pie ad what please
for the love of God do not spend five
million dollars on a pity pie ad in
Super Bowl just give it to me
okay I can directly take the money that
is also an available offer mr. B's I am
begging you do not spend five million
dollars not just because it's a complete
guide in waste of money but also because
I thank you
Thank You mr. B's if this video gets a
hundred thousand likes that mr. beast
has promised that he will donate five
million dollars directly to my bank
account what a great guy honestly thank
you so much what is this chunga Changa
chunga Changa omegle stranger fear the
chunga's junga junga junga junga junga
that's what I came for
do not post this and steal my UGG boots
you hear me sorry I'm deaf that's funny
I just realize that's a perfect excuse
for anything ah a blind excuse me why
did you copy strike all my videos I'm
blind what do you run from me sorry for
the quality and thanks for the people
that sort by new fish lasagna fish
lasagna
t-series ain't nothing but a [ __ ]
lasagna for this part really represent
my feeling it's a reflection of my
thoughts and deepest darkest secrets you
see the bee actually is time from four
[ __ ] and the L stands for lasagna not a
lot of people didn't pick up on man I'm
a blue-eyes White Dragon while you're
just Dark Magician well this part is
just nonsense I just threw it in there
to make the song longer that's right he
has no other meaning oh my god how did I
get away with that line
y-you wanna get some he'll I'm a
blue-eyes White Dragon while you're just
talking magician
you gotta fit help the population
education I'm a blue-eyes White Dragon
while you're just talking fish I'm a
blue-eyes White Dragon
while you're a Dark Magician well you're
just what has blue eyes and he's talking
about an Indian channel to tell if
racist the mental gymnastics how dare
you take those assumptions pokeyman smh
my head it means love and friendship go
copy strike someone pokeyman cuz that's
all you do I ain't a racism I am an anti
racism and I will not stand because I
physically came PewDiePie it gross I can
explain my Xia you're making five
hundred thousand and you're only giving
me thirty thousand Edgar thirty thousand
I'm only getting a thousand Brad one
you guys are getting picky no that's
Brad to the bottom ones are literally
brand and brand - this is practically
rice cribs apology video guys I can
explain
you're making two hundred thousand
dollars and you're giving away five
hundred and gift cards that five hundred
gift cards they were already claimed
girl says pity pie do girls even exist
girl says PewDiePie this is Thai epic
sub yeah it's funny because it's true
this is what happens when your audience
is a bunch of kids that drool over
nearly any single female
okay you guys gotta see this so this
girl that does the fingers cross on the
mobile strike she's the one that made
the ad I'll go with the scissor for me
suiting information when making this
commercial the inspiration behind it was
beauty behind that we made the
commercial around 20 late 2017 right you
would think that these specific mobile
ads had been around for a while like the
gameplay type but it actually had it my
sister who was working in the odds
department at Lourdes mobile she wrote
this script after her sister inspiration
and at the time I was obsessed with
PewDiePie Conan clueless gamer I told
her about them and then she wrote the
storyboard of this is our formation that
the sister perm Asia it was really funny
thank you anyway for being a good sport
about that that's hilarious when you're
watching the why but you've already seen
all the memes on the sub ready but now
we get to see them together isn't that
nice you have no friends and here so
here we are guys another look-alike okay
the whole look-alike thing and now oh I
already reviewed the subreddit I don't
need any more of this trash talk that
man looks nothing like me I review you
0pi [ __ ] girl this part is about my
father abandoning me as a child
don't let Felix forget what he promises
okay all right what is it now every time
there's they dig up something new eighty
million subs an owl host meme review oh
my god guys Peter pies are gonna always
remain review I did this as a final work
in art school what was your great
amazing this is an interesting way to
say you fail out of art school what
could someone who fails art school ever
hope to accomplish in their life nervous
loved one Kirk um no that's really cool
Rossler that's pretty epic man I truly
feel the pain eight months ago an editor
that worked for mr. beast try to exposed
beasts with lies for a class
and failed hard today mr. beast gave his
current editor a house this guy's giving
houses stop flexing on your editors mr.
B's what the hell oh man I can sense
Brad won and Brad to crying after this
Brad one and Brett - you want some g
fuel I have practically unlimited supply
would you like some just buy it
30% off excellent - you if you could
only watch one creator for the rest of
your life who would that be
everyone's a beauty pipe okay this is
one of the funniest things I've seen on
Twitter this week not just because
everyone kept riding PewDiePie but
because YouTube deliberately painfully
avoided every single comment the whole
meme that YouTube has to avoid me it's
not even a meme at this point if you
could watch only one creator in the rest
of your life who would it be PewDiePie
PewDiePie PewDiePie Peter if I hit it
hey did it put any but bit by bit about
bit about it just goes on but the
funniest part of this is the fact that
YouTube replies to the one person that
says iJustine it's good to take pride in
your work
she just misspelled PT pi is fine though
but if I had one of the most impactful
online presences in history in 2018
breaking multiple records gathering many
popular youtubers - his cost to keep a
single man above a soulless corporation
that's the most subscribers youtuber on
YouTube YouTube alright now we got all
the salt out we can move on to the memes
everyone show this to Felix can i divot
it everyone do you think the people that
conquered canada many many years ago I
don't know 50 years ago or whenever he
was do you think they went hey is gonna
be an epic meme because in Sweden we did
that as well I mean just look at Sweden
in Finland together and then you have
the little thing coming out as Denmark
anyway me refreshers mean up boats
doesn't change I'm not saying enough
movements guys kids just a reminder
don't gamble this fixes everything
thanks Jake s MH Jake Paul didn't even
give away used Amazon gift cards and you
call that an apology and this
if you're not giving away Amazon
giftcards don't even bother apologizing
I'm going to bring this gem here do that
I don't think I don't see it I generally
like that no they don't like the same
it's cold PewDiePie submissions but I've
never seen him submit okay moving on
okay so I send my friends screen of what
I ordered and yeah yeah yeah oh wait I
gotta show this de marzi ma yeah okay
look at this yeah you got the closed
door Vaman see this is why everyone
needs to bite sookie right freaking now
when you spend a hundred and eighty
hours why am I wearing this on minecraft
animations of bisque lasagna where
12,000 people wanted it but no one
watches it
wait why have my nuts nothing personal
kid oh my god oh Jesus Christ
[Music]
will it be number one but you lose
I can't believe our really likes in
Minecraft Wow technology has gone too
far under Elmer old 10 out of 10
thank you very much IRA got the Gores
I'm a suit day 11 proud of you boots
Pierce hasn't had a controversy in 2019
yet is that true no I don't think it's
true something's wrong here I don't like
you what do you think the next
controversy is going to be pin up Marcia
okay that's nice really dope subscribe
to PewDiePie key wits art on Instagram
Thank You cue bizarre that's really cool
what if my 8.1 thousand meme was seen by
Puetz but rad cut it out
this is what yeah this is what I've been
talking about all this time if a meme
doesn't end up on the Y it's literally
Brad's fault
all the time I have to write Brad
afterwards hey why did you cut that out
he just goes out and like that really
the one you got to suck up to his bread
if you want your mean to make is Hilda
why you just got it you just gotta suck
up to Brad one or bride - oopsie head
headgear elbow elbow gear need [ __ ] 2019
no controversy so far try again
Vox Vox are making memes and posting on
Amla why now killing it
level one crook level hundred slop
that's what I'm talkin about
wait is that Logan Pole merch who would
we're looking Paul merch ah
oopsie I accidentally put it on dude
should copy strike case I for reacting
to visual asagna oh he reacted to it
I'll this wait for the video to
accumulate a little bit more views then
it's striking time strike time don't
even think about private in the video I
still had the URL 80 million nine year
olds remember we may have won the battle
but the war is not over
come on guys Thank You boots very happy
well we see what
I thought about switching the set up but
then I'm like it's kind of maybe I
should maybe I should switch the set up
love it how he managed to advertise a
laptop his merch his books his chair
Logan pulled merch and a goddamn game in
one video did I actually do that
damn I'm slick Papa wants to buy a house
come on Felix grandpa explained get how
to defeat Norway they have no defenses
everyone knows this it's fine they don't
have defenses green screen
you guys just sure love to complain
don't you back then he had a simple
setup for gaming now he has an extremely
expensive fancy setup for looking at
memes dreams do come true guys you just
got to work hard for it if I reach 80
million subscribers I'll bring back shut
up I spent six hours in line to meet
pooj
but when I finally met him I was too shy
to say anything I hate myself
from this photo it just looks like you
waited six hours for me to just take a
selfie of myself which I guess is what
we did we can finally know Peter's real
height by knowing yours wanna help out
I'm 5 6 how tall is that you're 14
centimeters oh my god Felix is short I'm
5 8 I assumed he was giant since he's
Swedish I'm not sure 180 yeah I'm 180
Yeah right yeah right yeah right yeah ha
ha ha if the mark is 179 I'm their
Eiffel Tower ok imagine if I had legs
how tall I would be pets with one ear
that's just sad hey where did that go by
the way that's good that's really good
oh my god bawd appears on the train this
man is all over the world I don't even
remember it why am I looking at the
screen so intensively Jesus Christ what
is that I bet I'm playing in Lourdes
Mobile drooling over Zeus girls you
either die a hero or live long enough to
see yourself become a villain that's how
Brad works press X to steal we watch the
video
I read 721 books in 2018 in class today
because my TV thinks it's an important
video by reading books and she wanted us
all to see
she's also subscribing that's awesome
that's so cool what a difference from
the other teacher that would burn boy
there's a little note to and if you look
gonna play play finish teachers
shout-out to Finland very epic remember
this kid
this is him that actually but that's how
hadees works 2014 2015 2016 2017 2018 I
guess I haven't changed my style that
much are you sure about that
okay alright okay fine I get it excuse
me what the Frick I appreciate the
censored version of that mean oh my god
this is why Brad looks a hundred times
better as a female they have no defense
and they have all the oils hmm that's
all you had to say thanks for the tip
pills no problem um what you got there
smoothie calling all nine year olds or
14 year olds on Monday the 14th that's
today we will again create two accounts
to subscribe to pewdiepie if 10% of us
do it we will raise 16 million easily
and if 30 percent discount we can buy up
the G fuel stock think about it let's
make it happen
80 million subscribers 80 million
mergers out thank you again for all the
support
I'm so glad and lucky to have such an
amazing fan base I do appreciate you
guys
sometimes smash like goodbye see you
tomorrow
ah gee what's he gonna upload then can't
wait dude I see you tomorrow it's gonna
be epic
tomorrow's video can we get some hype
for tomorrow's video it's gonna be so
good check out another video goodbye
tired of standing up I mean I'm tired of
tired of nothing
you thought this video was not long
enough we have one more thing the most
important thing of all time did I make
it on the top hundred most handsome
faces in 28 I mean I already know
everyone's been tweeting at me for some
reason for some goddamn reason I am NOT
just on the top hundred most handsome
faces list I'm not just in the top ten
no that's right everyone mariana DVI Oh
get out of here
Marlin tick Sierra sue me my sin Shawn
Mendes [ __ ] more like Shawn Hume Shawn
oh how the reigning champ that's right I
beat the reigning champ king tides human
the month that way the person that looks
like a goddamn God basically okay and
yes sweetie
ah it hurts my sites I don't know how
this happens every year but I'll take it
okay I'll take you can't wait to see the
become as everyone roasting me here it
is ladies and gentlemen the guy who
fixes 2018 oh so people are nice Harry
Styles yeah you must be joking it didn't
see piercing to an eighteen rewind but
did see him in hundred months something
went wrong in 2018 we're still trying to
work it out but thank you very much
TC Chandler absolutely incredible
dream big and memes can get you
literally anywhere in life that's it i
beat kim jong-in that's it thank you
guys smash like